This is Jocko podcast number 58 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening.
No,
a couple of shows ago when Dr Peter Attia was on,
he mentioned an article,
and I hesitate to call it an article because it is actually much more than just
an article.
It's an elegant piece that was published in the New York Times written by his
friend and the daughter of one of his mentors,
a woman named Naomi Rosenberg,
Dr Naomi Rosenberg,
who is a doctor at Temple University.
And Peter said that this article truly captured the emotions and the struggle
and the methodology for delivering the worst news to a parent that their child
had died.
Okay.
And I of course read the article and I found it incredible and I wanted to share
it with you
in case you didn't have a chance to read it yourself yet.
So here it is from the opinion section of the New York Times on September 3rd,
2016 by Dr Naomi Rosenberg,
how to tell a mother her child is dead
first.
You get your coat.
I don't care if you don't remember where you left it,
you find it.
If there was a lot of blood,
you ask someone to go quickly to the basement to get you a new set of scrubs.
You put on your coat and you go into the bathroom.
You look into the mirror and you say it.
You use the mother's name and you use her child's name.
You may not adjust this part in any way.
I will show you.
If it were my mother,
you would say,
Mrs Rosenberg,
I have terrible,
terrible news.
Naomi died today.
You say it out loud until you can say it clearly and loudly.
How loudly
loud enough.
If it takes you fewer than five tries,
you are rushing it and you will not do it right.
You take your time
after the bathroom,
you do nothing before you go to her.
You don't make a phone call.
You do talk to the medical student.
You do not put in an order.
You'll never make her wait.
She is his mother.
When you get inside the room,
you will know who the mother is.
Yes,
I am very sure.
Okay,
shake her hand and tell her who you are.
If there is time you shake everyone's hand.
Yes,
you will know if there is time
you never stand.
If there are no seats left,
the couches have arms on them,
you will have a decision to make about whether you will ask her what she already
knows.
If you were the one to call her and tell her that her son had been shot,
then you already have done part of it,
but you have not done it yet.
Yeah,
you are about to do it now.
You never make her wait.
She is his mother
now.
You explode the world.
Yes,
you have to.
You say something like,
Mrs. Booker,
I have terrible,
terrible news.
Earnest died today.
Then you wait.
You will not stand up.
You may leave yourself in the heaviness of your breath or the racing of your
pulse or the site of your shoe laces on your shoe,
but you will not stand up.
You are here for her.
She is his mother.
If the mother has another son with her and he has punched the wall or broken the
chair,
do not be worried.
The one that punched a wall or broke the chair will be better than the one who
looks down and refuses to cry.
The one who punched the wall or broke the chair will be much easier than the
sister who looks up and closes her eyes as they fill.
Yeah.
Security is already outside the room and when they hear the first loud noise,
they will know to come in.
Okay.
No,
you will not have to tell them.
They know about the family room in the emergency department in summer in North
Philadelphia.
It is all right.
They will be kind.
If the chair cannot be sat in again.
That is all right.
We have money for new chairs every summer.
If he does not break your chair,
you stay in your chair.
If he does,
you find a new place to sit.
You are here for the mother and you have more to do.
If she asks you,
you were teller.
What you know you do not lie,
but do not say he was murdered or he was killed.
Yes,
I know that he was,
but that is not what you say.
You say that he died.
That is the part that you saw and that you know
when she asks if he felt any pain,
you must be very careful
if he did not.
You assure her quickly.
If he did,
you do not lie,
but his pain is over.
Now
do not ever say he was lucky that he did not feel pain.
He was not lucky.
She is not lucky.
Don't make that face.
The depth of the stupidity of the things you will say sometimes is unimaginable
before you leave.
You break her heart one more time.
No,
I'm sorry,
but you cannot see him.
There are strict rules.
When a person dies this way and the police have to take him first.
We cannot let you in.
I'm so sorry.
You do not ever say the body.
It is not a body.
It is her son.
You want to tell her that you know that he was hers,
but she knows that and she does not need for you to tell her.
Instead,
tell her you will give her time and come back in case she has questions,
more questions or questions for the first time.
If she has no questions,
you do not give her the answers to the questions she has not asked.
Okay?
When you leave the room,
do not yell at the medical student who has a question.
When you get home,
do not yell at your husband
if he left his socks on the floor again today.